where the heck is the high-end mac mini  and how much is it gonna cost and is  there a chance that it could pack in an  insane 20 core m1 max duo chip with a  massive 64 gpu course i don't think that  apple will wait longer than march to  reveal this new mac mini i feel pretty  confident that apple will actually sell  this new m1 pro mac mini at a starting  base price of just 12.99 john prosser  revealed some renders of the new mac  mini that him and ian zelbo were able to  create using leaked cad files and other  bits of info so what i did was match up  the size and scale of the current m1 mac  mini and these new renders showing that  the new high-end mac mini is going to be  significantly slimmer it makes it  incredibly hard to believe that apple  could even fit enough cooling  performance to cool down a crazy 20 core  m1 max duo chip with 64 gpu cores